although she may not know it Anne Carson
is one of the patron saints of rain
taxi I don't exactly mean the
accomplished and much beloved author who
joins us here tonight but rather the an
Carson we reviewed 16 years ago in our
second issue a then much less known
writer whose recently published book
glass irony and God made us want to
shout from the rooftops or at least
start a magazine that here was something
utterly new in the well-worn landscape
of
literature in that respect of course it
is the same an Carson since we and so
many others have continued to want to
get up on those
rooftops though preceded by iros The
Bitter Suite which felt equally like a
volcanic eruption in the field of the
essay glass irony and God was followed
by an astonishing array of texts that
appeared under the sign of poetry
including such works as autobiography of
red men in the off hours
decreation and the beauty of the husband
not to mention the riveting translations
from the Greek that comprise the books
grief lessons and Arista and if not
winter her most recent work is the
aforementioned and staggeringly gorgeous
Knox an accordion folded book housed in
a clamshell box which is both a word by
word meditation on an elegy by catellis
and a heart-wrenching elegy in its own
right Anne Carson is a writer who is
fascinated with dualities and
contradictions her work is often
strongly narrative but the emotional
chord it strikes is deeply rooted in
language and
lyric it often derives from ancient ient
texts that inform her background as a
classicist but it is relentlessly
contemporary it often deals with loss
and grief but It ultimately affirms life
and of course there is the genre
blurring for which she is so justly
admired the novel the essay the poem The
Dance the film The Treatise the
translation the lecture the Opera the
artist's book The Autobiography and more
all forms of creative expression become
intertwined in Carson's unique vision of
poetry this too coincides with her
fondness for collaboration in the past
decade and a half she has worked with
dancers musicians visual artists and
students across the country to push the
art form of poetry in new directions for
her work she has been honored with many
awards including the lanon literary
award the TS Elliot prize the Griffin
poetry prize prize and a MacArthur
Fellowship she has also assembled one of
the largest and most passionate
audiences of any living poet which is no
mean feat as Dylan Hicks whim
whimsically summed up in yesterday's
City Pages an Carson tends to divide
people into two camps those who haven't
gotten around to her yet and those who
think she's a genius speaking from that
latter group let me put the bottom line
and I'm there at last as simp simply as
possible Anne Carson is one of the
greatest poets writing in the English
language and it gives me great pleasure
to introduce her on this stage tonight
please welcome Anne
[Applause]
Carson um thank you
Eric feel a little overwhelmed by the
introduction but try to pop back
um it's a great honor to be here and
thank you for
coming and I think in the spirit of
occupy Minneapolis which is
struggling struggling
on those poor souls I think six of them
in their sleeping bags down at the what
is it called Government Center in the
cold we should dedicate the reading to
them I think and in the um Spirit of
them I'd like to start with something a
little bit
interactive kind of
a on the model of their human microphone
thing that they do with calling back in
the
crowd um this is a short talk short talk
is a 13c lecture on this or that
topic and this one is
called short talk on
reading and how it works is I say my
part then you shout out your part and it
comes together to form a tiny meaning so
for this short talk your script is the
word
deciduous with an exclamation mark at
the end no a question mark at the end
sorry question mark So deciduous like
that so 1 2
fantastic don't forget your
line short talk on
reading some fathers hate to read but
love to take the family on trips some
children hate trips but love to read
funny how often these find themselves
passengers in the same
automobile I glimpsed the stupendous
clear-cut shoulders of the Rockies from
between paragraphs of Madame boy Cloud
Shadows roved languidly across her huge
Rock throat traced her fur
flanks and since those days I do not
look at hair on female flesh without
thinking thank
you that's part of my project to occupy
reason
so I'm going to start with a um an essay
I've been writing sort of Pros lately
this is from just a week ago or
so um yeah so it's called we point the
bone an essay on
threat little tough ones Little Tall
ones like little tall trees others
yellow as hay their tiny blades falling
across the cracks the
stones blades moving a
bit there is no reason for you to wonder
about this keep listening keep glancing
out small grasses in the
driveway perhaps following two lines of
thought at once as a person does on the
telephone on an ordinary day little
grasses like that pushing up thrusting
their way
can be expected in time to dissect and
overturn the whole driveway and how
strange this voice you do not recognize
is using your name talking about you as
he saying he had an accident very bad
accident very bad taken to the hospital
very bad Hospital must proceed at once
he
you no ladders go up to this moment
where you perceive the second person cut
from the third person within you and it
all drops off into a past tense that
will not have happened yet click dial
tone the little grasses look weak and
cold pity them don't pity them watch
yourself you didn't know the blades hung
in your
mouth the word threat comes from Old
English threat coercion and Middle High
German Dr annoyance also associated with
the Latin verb truda to push thrust
shove people so pushed will leave town
for a while 6 months a year return
quietly see how things go resume as they
say normal
life keep listening keep an ear cocked
wake up
stinging you will dream of a man who
hastens along pulling off a piece of his
his face as he passes drops it on the
sidewalk telephones are not the only way
you receive your own obituary in the
mail a person in Black stops before you
in the street then hurries
away and suddenly at 6:00 in the morning
as if swept by winter Rivers everything
changes your telephone your kitchen your
driveway all these things that had a
notion of you now change their gaze and
watch you from a different place no two
places everything now happens from two
places you brush your teeth in the
second and in the third person you stand
at the window in the second and in the
third
person watching the driveway waiting
perhaps for your child who is late from
school you sweat from those
places so I was crossing the schoolyard
one morning Saturdays I go to early bike
class at the gym I take a shortcut
through the yard behind the local school
the yard has swings and monkey bars in a
sort of rough basketball court with
benches for
parents I love the clear empty light of
Saturday morning there is no one in the
churchard in the schoolyard at that hour
except usually a guy reading a
newspaper the guy sits not on on the
benches but on the edge of a low Stone
retaining wall that marks off the
basketball court from the
swings he balances exactly on the wall
with one leg crossed over the other he
doesn't look
up it's funny you can tell just from how
a person sits reading the newspaper that
he's off the grid in some essential way
economically mentally who knows I don't
like to say homeless he's not unclean he
wears regular clothes a sort of sports
coat he has no collection of stuff
parked nearby just his
newspaper yet he is different sharper
sharpened on the
air he and I don't look at one another
straight I cross the schoolyard briskly
normally he is on my left as I
cross I do not feel his eyes on my back
when I exit via the little path that
runs along the sixth grade science
classroom past the two old Steelcase
doors still marked boys and girls onto
the
street but that one morning when I
crossed the yard he wasn't there I
registered this with half my mind I was
a bit late and had put my t-shirt on
backwards the label was bothering my
neck anyway I kept going stepped onto
the little path glanced into the science
classroom and was partway down the path
to the street when something white that
was pushing itself up through my
attention on the left formed into a
thought white thing boys girls I stopped
and
turned in the place where he would have
been sitting on the wall was a whiteness
like a pile of
paper I don't have time to investigate
this I thought I'm already late and I
continued to head down the path for the
street a crease went through me that's
the way it felt a piece of me folded
over in a crease inside and lay flat
knife
edged I stopped I turned again I
approached the white pile it looked like
pieces of torn newspaper words torn out
heaped on the stone wall no not words
single letters a careful job of
tearing I was late for my class but I
had to stop sit down on the wall study
the letters arrange them this way and
that nine letters alphabetically a b e d
l l m o
o other ways
doil
mol badly
Loom blood M blood
meal I
paused I looked at the red stain
revealed by I moving the letters from
their original place on the stone a dark
red stain recent but
dry I thought about the bike class gave
up on it glanced up the street and down
the street quiet backyards in every
direction one behind the other How
Deeply they nested like bowls of graded
sizes some empty some
cluttered I am someone who knows about
stains it's my business
I do cleaning also I have occasionally
been engaged as an expert witness in
criminal
investigations expert witnessing is well
paid much can be inferred from a
stain this one for
example I glanced up the street again
vaguely expecting to see the Egret then
remembered it had been kidnapped some
rich people a judge and his striking
Northern wife who live up the street
have an ornamental Pond they used to
keep a pet Egret in the backyard until
the judge fell a foul of certain local
cocaine financiers and the Egret got
snatched Ransom was paid they
slaughtered the Egret anyway life went
on for the judge who persevered in his
efforts to clear our small town of
drugs one day the local newspaper
published a political cartoon about the
judge he his involvement in some
Municipal controversy I can't remember
now and there in the backyard stood in
the background stood the tall white-
skinned wife balanced on one leg in what
looked like an ornamental
Pond the judicial procedure was soon
discontinued technical reasons and there
went my hopes for a Christmas vacation
in Rio I had been scheduled to testify
about various stains found in various
places
at various crime scenes and as I say the
pay is
good but now bloodmeal was Furnishing me
with several points to
consider letters cut out with scissors
not sloppily done different fonts but
all caps and roughly the same font size
so the word laid out on the retaining
wall looked emphatic but amiable not
crazy the blood for it was blood showed
a stain pattern not created by passive
drops gravity but swiped onto the stone
human purpose its viscosity indicating
leakage from a lower extremity not a
major organ and not copious it was a few
hours
old the body goes dark inside and out at
times the Mind shuts
down my mind started up again again in a
peak why were they threatening me with
minor wounds to a person I scarcely knew
and did not care about this is meager I
thought this is feeble what a palid
degree of enemy I am to them I was on
some level
insulted yet my reactions felt
rudderless I struggled to get hold of
them let's review the facts my facts
mother and father gone no children wife
or water fowl someone would have to
grasp at straws to find a way of
menacing
me I went to a conference of heatonist
in Kau last year people who analyze
blood stains for forensic purpose are a
varied lot as you might imagine but a
kind of bluff stoicism seems
characteristic of them queasiness not an
option pity not an option facts are what
matter striding about the old St streets
of kakow in the small hours of the night
I couldn't sleep I was pondering ethical
types every blood spatter analysis is
proof that strength alone cannot earn
you the world you with your bludgeon
raised I can know you I can read your
Trace people who do violence or who
threaten to do violence do thereby to
some extent reveal themselves
my point is that rising from the
retaining wall and stuffing blood meal
into my pocket I began almost to enjoy
myself matching wits is the best thing
in life it's like tits to me both sex
and
nourishment clearly I would have to
rethink my role in The War on Drugs at
least locally meanwhile I was involved
with worthy opponents intelligent maybe
not but they understood close
observation of facts and their interest
in the nuances of me would eventually
show me their
own I felt cocky I felt singular I Rose
to my full outline sharp and white
against the
day no more bite classes I opened my
research I got out all the old reports
began sifting the judge's data working
out a certain picture of how things went
down during this time I stopped
answering my cell phone and forgot to
eat there were a couple dozen packets of
gummy bears in the fridge and some
ryvita I had subsisted on these also
during this time occurred the action at
the schoolhouse here I had to lean my
head on my notebook and weep our local
school Master a brave and Innovative
Soul decided to not pay the spring
semester's installment of protection
money and see where that
led it led to to a Wednesday in March
when the entire student body give or
take a few kids home with colds or flu
was mowed down by Machine Gun fire as it
emerged For Recess those chubby
advancing knees boys girls I was not
enjoying myself
anymore several nights I went and stood
outside the judge's house and watched
Dark shapes move behind his blinds the
pond lay still
threat is a communication system that
functions best with a high level of
noise my research had narrowed down to
five people I found out a lot about them
facts every fact available I used
regular male priority male Parcels faxes
FedEx a dead fox money and Messengers in
Black I used sulfur pollen beet juice
blackberries meat ashes urine rust semen
feces and blood of every type in my lab
I threatened everything those five
people were or did or knew or hoped or
had kinship with I polluted every
surface they met touched or saw in the
course of the day and every place their
dreams went in the black sleep of night
I confused their categories and
contaminated their
information one of them received a pizza
with his wife's email password in black
olives across the
top and his Mistresses underneath in
roasted red
pepper next day both women changed their
passwords I sent another
Pizza does it sound like I was having a
mar and mischievous time in fact there
was no mood I can name expert or not it
was all so clumsy nothing I did matched
what they had done or tied off the Loose
Ends of sin I was flailing at trauma I
worked without realistic expectation of
follow through I'm not much good at
actual harm still it felt better to me
to live this way than to be circling my
perfect calves on a bike at the
gym I meant to lower the quality of
those five lives just a bit every minute
of their lives that I could reach make a
small Mark nothing
Sublime you know that drop of the heart
you feel when you turn and see
stain I lasted a couple of
months in ancient times there were
tribes who rode into battle shooting
volleys of curses before them little
papers attached to arrows such as those
now fluttering down across my windows in
a white storm I do not see the
wording feeling my way upstairs in the
dark someday I can't remember mourning
in
old mothy smell in my nose how I hate
carpeted stairs why have I never
replaced those
stairs I imagine the old tried and true
language we curse your night and day we
take your blood away we point the
bone they will arrive this evening or
possibly
tomorrow if I call don't pick up the
phone let me leave a postumus message
I've always wanted to do
[Applause]
that that's it for
pros I shall Now read some
translations of my favorite Roman poet
catalis he lived in the first century
and sort of invented lyric poetry for
the
Romans um yeah I'll read the Latin title
of each one which is the first line of
each one they didn't have titles in
Latin verse first Salway NEC minimo
pelazo hello not very small noosed
girl in this poem catalis compares an
unnamed girl to his own
love your nose is wrong your feet are
wrong your eyes are wrong your mouth is
wrong your pimp is wrong even his name
is wrong who cares what they say you're
not oh why can't I live in the 19th
century yam where aalos refer
Tores now spring brings warms in this
poem catalus greets the season of
spring now spring unlocks now the
Equinox stops its blue rages quiet as
pages I tell you leave Troy leave the
ground burning they did look we will
change everything all the meanings all
the clear cities of Asia you and
me now the mind isn't she an avid
previous
hobo now the feet grow leaves so glad to
see whose green baits
awaits oh sweet don't go back the same
way go a new
way Hino lini
Dei yesterday linius at our
ease in this poem catalus addresses his
friend linius with
affection I guess around Sunset we
started to drink and lay on the floor
writing lines for songs that cold night
smell coming in the window I left about
4 went home opened the fridge closed it
lay down got up lay down lay turned not
mourning yet I just want to talk to you
why does love happen so then I grew old
and died and wrote this be careful it's
World
sharp Kylie lesbia Nostra lesbia IL our
lesbia that
lesbia in this poem catalis finds his
own Love Gone to
others nuns coated in silver were not so
naked as our night interviews now what
Plum is your tongue
in huh
nonan quiam raer pwi I thought it no
matter in this poem catalis is in a
disparaging mood about his friend
ianus I've been looking up words for
anus to describe imus's mouth ARS ass
breach bum butt butthole buttock cowle
appendage croo crer dorsal root
fundament hind gut posterior opening of
the elementary Canal rectal Red Bud rump
UMC Withers UMC smell
it good old calus
I'm going to read some now from noox
which is a book that came out last
year
um originally it was a book that I made
by hand with paintings and stuff in it
and then it languished for a decade and
then my friend Curry who's here figured
out how it could be designed and
reproduced as a book for other people so
um
we did
that uh it's a book about my brother who
lived a strange life and died a
mysterious death and the book is sort of
an Epitaph for him it's organized as
Eric said earlier around a poem of
catellus um who wrote an Epitaph for his
brother who died
untimely um so in the book
I disassemble the poem of could tell us
one word at a time and put that word on
the left page with the dictionary
definition and on the right hand page
something about my brother so it weaves
back and forth so I'll read a little
from both sides of the
pages and I'll begin with the the
catellis poem in Latin it's poem
101 molas Peres at M
[Music]
Mori nen
inter prisco
manin
W molas from molus multa multum
adjective numerous many many are of many
are many people many women The Ordinary
People the many especially in phrase un
multis one of many many things much to a
great extent many words especially in
elliptical phrases for example quid MTA
NE MTA to cut a long story short an
abundance of much large molum EST it is
of value appearing or acting on many
occasions assiduous regular used many
times of persons too much inevidence
tedious wearisome verbose occurring in a
high degree full Intense madz or Mula
looks broad daylight mola knocks late in
the night perhaps too
late
1.0 I wanted to fill my elery with light
of all kinds but death makes us
stingy there is nothing more to be
expended on that we think he's dead love
cannot alter it words cannot add to it
no matter how I try to evoke the star
lad he was it remains a plain odd
history so I began to think about
history 1.2
autopsy is a term historians use of the
eyewitnessing of data or events by the
historian himself a mode of authorial
power to withhold this authorization is
also so
powerful Herodotus carefully does not
allege to have seen a phoenix which
comes only once every 500 years although
he mentions the same old Legends as
heus roditus likes to introduce such
information with a word like legai it is
said as one might use on D or
diur when my brother died his dog got
angry stayed angry barking growling
lashing glaring by day and night he went
to the door he went to the window he
would not lie
down my brother's widow it is said took
the dog to the church on the day of the
funeral Buster goes right up to the
front of s Johannes and raises himself
on his paw on the edge of the coffin and
as soon as he smells the fact his anger
stops to be nothing is that not after
all the most satisfactory fact in the
whole world asks a dog in a novel I read
once I wonder what the smell of nothing
is smell of autop
y
2.2 my brother ran away in
1978 rather than go to jail he wandered
in Europe and India seeking something
and sent us postcards or Christmas gift
no return
address he was traveling on a false
passport and living under other people's
names this isn't hard to arrange it's is
IR
remediable I don't know how he made his
decisions in those days the postcards
were
laconic he wrote only one letter to my
mother the winter the girl
died
3.1 my brother dies in Copenhagen in the
year 2000 a surprise to
me 3.2
I go to Copenhagen my brother's widow
gives me some old diar she found from
his wandering years filled with
photographs that he developed himself in
hotel rooms of Hyderabad Bangalore
Amsterdam catmandu Paris of the girl who
died usually naked except for some
jewelry a blonde delighted
girl she was the love of his life his
widow says calmly
4.1 my brother did not marry the blonde
delighted girl he married two that I
know of other women during those years
one of whom divorced him the other is
now his
widow he confuses me the times overlap
what matters is they each adored him
with his blue eyes and broken front
tooth light of my life as his widow now
says and oddly into me drops this
expression my mother used
also I can see her standing at the
kitchen sink scraping
carrots for years after he left she
would glance up every time a car came
spinning along the
road
4.2 she never got an address for him
indeed during the last seven years of
her life he wrote to her not a single
word eventually she began to say he was
dead how do you know I said and she said
when I pray for him nothing comes
back
4.3 after that we didn't talk of my
brother hopelessness built a wall in her
I wasn't sure new feelings were finished
arriving from him yet but there was no
practical reason to say so it was a
relief not to have him dropping through
every conversation like a smell of
burning hair to be honest from my point
of view from her point of view all
desire left the
world
5.1 what he needed from me I have no
idea when I caught up to him in high
school he was older by four years he
liked me to do his homework but that
wasn't it my moral advice he brushed
aside you're different he would say he
called me Professor or pin head epithets
implying intellectual respect but we
never had a conversation about ideas in
our life and when he telephoned me out
of the blue about half a year after our
mother died
he had nothing to
say this is a telephone conversation me
him me mother is dead him yes I guess
she is me she had a lot of pain because
of you him yes I guess she did me why
didn't you write him well it was hard
for me me are you sick him no me do you
work him yes me are you happy him no oh
no kinm from kinis keris masculine noun
compare Greek
KES the residue from a fire ashes in
medicine ashes of various materials
kenis cyprius oxide of copper kenis
liiva lie the ex or apparently extinct
ashes of a fire hot Ember by which food
is cooked the spent or smoldering fires
of Love or
enmity ashes regarded as the result of
waste or destruction Troya wum at nocum
aera kinis Troy bitter Ash of men and
knights ashes as a condition of the body
after death as a stage in existence the
grave in seul
inscriptions kenis hick doct Pella Fu
this ash was a scholarly
girl
5.2 his voice on the phone was like his
voice with something else crusted on it
black and dense it lighted up for a
moment when he said Pinhead so Pinhead
do you attain wisdom yet then went dark
again all the years and time that had
passed over him came streaming into me
all that
history what is a
voice
5.4 my brother's widow takes me to the
church called sank Johannes where the
funeral was held two weeks ago it is
white and clean as an eggshell inside I
like cleanliness my brother didn't care
so much
when he came to Stay With Me In
1978 two weeks before he ran away the
apartment got dirty cigarette butts
everywhere and At Last I was glad he
moved on one morning he bed a cigarette
in the frying pan on the stove Sunny
Side
Up
6.1 when my brother died unexpectedly
his wife his widow couldn't find a phone
number for me among his papers until 2
weeks later while I swept my porch and
bought apples and sat by the window in
the evening with the radio on his death
came wandering slowly towards me across
the
sea
7.1 I want to explain about the catalis
poem catalis wrote poem 101 for his
brother who Di died in the
troad nothing at all is known of the
brother except his death catalis appears
to have traveled from Verona to Asia
Minor to stand at the grave perhaps he
recited the elery
there I have loved this poem since the
first time I read it in high school
Latin class and I have tried to
translate it a number of
times nothing in English can capture the
passionate slow surface of a Roman elegy
no one even in Latin can approximate
cataland diction which at its most
sorrowful has an air of deep
festivity like one of those trees that
turns all its leaves over silver in the
wind I never arrived at the translation
I would have liked to do of poem
101 but over the years of working at it
I came to think of translating as a room
not exact ly an unknown room where one
gropes for the light switch I guess it
never ends a brother never ends I prowel
him he does not
end prowling the meanings of a word
prowling the history of a person no use
expecting a flood of light human words
have no main
switch but all those little kidnaps in
the dark and then the Luminous big
shivering discandy unrepentant barking
web of them that hangs in your mind when
you turn back to the page you were
trying to
translate take the word entry as used of
the arrangement of the contents of a
lexicon in one sense it is a room I can
never leave perhaps dreadful for that
at the same time a place composed
entirely of
entries is it not
astonishing
entry
7.2 my brother's widow says she rented a
boat and went up the coast to put his
ashes in the sea at Sunset near the
castle of helenor she threw sunflowers
after
you know what they do she asks me they
turn around on the
water festive I say festive in their
way I'll end with the catellis poem in
English many the peoples many the oceans
I crossed I arrive at these poor brother
burials so I could give you the last
gift owed to death and talk why with
mute
Ash now that fortune tore you from me
you oh poor wrongly brother wrongly
taken from me now still anyway this what
a distant mood of parents handed down as
the sad gift for
burials
accept soaked with tears of a
brother and into forever brother
farewell and
farewell catellis
101 thank you
[Applause]